- He's the kind of person
we should listen to.
There's a reason he
rose in such popularity,
because people are
resonating with his ideas.
Now, even if I don't, I
can at least recognize,
well, there's a voice maybe
I should pay attention to.
I might learn something from him.
(dynamic music)
- Hey, I'm Dave Rubin, and
this is "The Rubin Report.
Reminder, everybody, you
can get all our videos
and audio podcasts
absolutely ad-free and early
at RubinReport.com.
And joining me today is the
publisher of "Skeptic" magazine,
host of the Science Salon Podcast
and author of the new book,
"Giving the Devil His Due."
Michael Shermer, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Good to be back, the tournament
of champions continues.
(laughing)
- We've had a couple of
technical difficulties today
to make this thing
happen, but here we are.
I know that as a man of
faith, you're gonna pray
that our connection does--
- I'm praying away.
I'm not gonna try to pray
away the gay for you,
but I'm gonna try to pray
away the coronavirus bugs
in our computer systems here.
It's the 5G, you see.
(laughing)
- Oh, it's definitely the 5G.
It's coming for everybody.
It's spreading coronavirus
and the rest of it.
All right, there's a
ton I wanna get to here,
because I really love this book,
and I just said to you
right before we started
that so much in my book as well,
we really cover the topics,
but come to slightly different conclusions
on a couple of things and the
way we approach the topics
is a little bit different each time.
But before we get to the book itself,
you've written 16 books.
And as a guy that just wrote one
and knows what it takes to write one,
how do you possibly not only
come up with enough material,
but enough sort of personal fortitude
and patience and all of it
to just be able to sit there
and put all of those
thoughts out 16 times?
And quite successfully, by the way.
It's not like nobody's
reading these things.
- Yeah, well, thank
you, I appreciate that.
Well, first of all, I'm 65,
so I've got a couple of
decades on you or almost,
(laughing)
just cumulative time, but I
also started writing in my 20s.
When I was in college, actually,
I always wanted to be a writer.
And then by the time
I got to my early 30s,
I had written quite a bit
that wasn't published,
just practicing stuff and
trying to get things published,
such that by my first
book, let's see, in 1997,
so I was 30, let's see, 33,
no, let's see, no, I was 43,
I had quite a bit of material.
- 43 at my first book, I'm with you.
- See, see, that's right.
So each book kinda ends
with a question of sorts,
or in my mind anyway,
that's the next book.
And it's also a strategy
when you're cutting,
'cause I usually write too much material,
and then I think, "Oh, I really
don't wanna give this up,"
and I can talk myself
into doing that by saying,
"I'll put it in the next book,"
and then it shortens that book.
So you don't feel like
you've wasted your time.
By temperament, I feel
like if I don't write
pretty much every day, it's
like if I don't go work out,
if I don't ride my bike, I feel anxious,
like I really need to write,
I just have a need for it.
I know other people, like
Isaac Asimov is that way,
apparently Stephen King is like that.
They just gotta crank out the
material 'cause it feels good.
It's just sort of what I do,
like an artist paints, I write, whatever.
So I find a lot it's not a chore.
I don't have writer's block,
per se, I have time block.
I just need more time 'cause I enjoy it.
- One of the things that
I really like that you do,
and it's not just in this book,
it's in really all of your books,
or at least the last few
since I've known you,
is you give credit to a lot
of the other current thinkers
that are talking about these things,
and I think that's actually
a kinda unique trait,
because a lotta people wanna sit there
and make it seem like they
came up with all of this.
But even I was looking at the blurbs
in the back of the book,
and actually it's a Rubin
Report reunion over here
'cause you've got Stephen
Pinker, Jordan Peterson,
Nadine Strossen, Nick
Christakis, Amy Chua,
and Jonathan Haidt, and these
are people that you reference.
- And they've all been on your show.
- No, they've all been on
the show, which is nice,
but that is one of the things
that I like about this book
because you reference a lotta
these people and their ideas
as sort of the starting
point or maybe midpoint
for how you think about things.
Were you always that way,
that you would hear somebody
and kinda mirror what
you think against them?
- Yeah, to a certain
extent, but as a writer
and as a consumer of many other books,
I can see some authors are more generous
about crediting where
their ideas came from
and sort of tracking for the reader
how they came up with their
thesis of the book or whatever.
Others not so much.
I'm not gonna name any names,
but some people do write in a way
like they just came out
of this whole cloth,
it just popped into my
brain, like the muses.
No ideas happen like that.
We all build on each
other, everybody does.
In scholarly papers, you have to cite
just tons and tons and tons of references,
and that's why sometimes
the reference sections
are as long as the papers themselves.
So I always felt like,
well, I wanna be generous
and just honest and say
here's where I came up
with these ideas 'cause
of these three authors
or these 16 sources, or whatever.
Anyway, so I just got in
the habit of doing that
just from training as an
experimental psychologist initially
and then a historian of science,
you just have to do that.
But just personally, I
feel when I see that,
someone like Richard Dawkins
is very generous about that,
as is Steve Pinker, and of deciding
where all these ideas come
from, quoting other people.
And it's like, I like that,
I wanna make sure I do that, too.
- So one other thing
before we dive specifically
into the topics in the book,
because you have now been
on "The Rubin Report"
at least six times, which
places you at number one,
which I'm sure despite
your rather lofty resume,
I'm sure that's clearly
at the top of the list.
But for somebody that's
watching this right now
that just doesn't know anything about you,
can you just give me a
two or three minute recap
on how you kinda became
the skeptic's skeptic?
- Yeah, well, my day job is
publishing "Skeptic" magazine
and directing the Skeptic
Society, which is a 501(c)(3)
nonprofit science education organization.
I got interested in the topis,
which is pretty much any of
the super interesting topics
related to science and
religion and spirituality
and cults and free will
and determinism and God.
Pretty much all the great
topics I'm interested in.
It really goes back to being in college,
and I was a born-again Christian.
In 1971, when I was in 11th
grade, I had two close friends
who were interested in converting me,
I didn't even know what
that meant, really,
George and Frank.
So George had a really cute
sister and invited me to church.
I thought, well, okay, here's my chance.
(laughing)
But then when I got to the church,
it was this Presbyterian
church in Glendale, California,
and the minister was unbelievably dynamic
and just really motivating,
and at the end he said,
"Come on up and you can accept Jesus,
"the whole thing will happen right here,"
and I'm like, all right, I'm going.
So I went, but I didn't even
know what I doing, really.
But I did it and then
took it pretty seriously.
And then I went to Pepperdine University,
which is a Church of Christ
school and very conservative.
Gerald Ford came to speak
and Edward Teller came
and gave his mutual
assured destruction speech,
and everyone was, Ayn Rand,
"Atlas Shrugged" and all that,
pretty much what you'd expect.
But then when I went to graduate school,
I kinda drifted away from being religious,
mainly for two reasons.
One, studying social psychology,
anthropology, sociology,
I could see that other people's
religious belief systems
are very much context-dependent,
geographically-dependent.
So had I been born in India,
I very likely would not be Christian.
Had I been born 10,000 years ago,
there would be no Christians, right?
So it seemed to me that
that doesn't make it wrong,
but it makes it more likely
to be mythically true,
as our friend Jordan Peterson would say,
not empirically true.
- [Dave] We're gonna get into that.
- Yeah, yeah, but then
also the problem of evil,
the theodicy, why bad things
happen to good people.
And I'm not talking about
like a human volition
of homicide or war or something like that,
but just like innocent
children dying of leukemia
or thousands of children dying
from starvation every year, and so on.
It's like, why would a good
God allow that to happen?
I know there's tons of books and papers
by theists and theologians about this,
but to me they've never
squared that circle,
they've never solved that problem,
other than like Rabbi
Kushner's famous book,
"When Bad Things Happen to Good People."
His conclusion was God simply
can't do anything about it.
He's not omniscient.
I mean, he's not omnipotent.
He may know everything, but
he can't stop evil, okay.
So that's one solution.
Another one is, well,
there just is no God.
And that's the simpler solution to me,
and that explains a lot,
because if you understand
the laws of physics
and say the Second Law of
Thermodynamics, entropy,
just shit happens.
It's mostly just random (chuckles)
and there's very little
directionality to why things happen
other than just statistical probabilities,
and that's it, there's nothing to explain.
So like the coronavirus, what's the cause?
500 years ago it would have been,
well, women have been
cavorting with demons
in the middle of the night,
or the Jews poisoned the well,
or some of these crazy
supernatural paranormal,
and a racist, bigoted
targeting of peoples.
Well, we don't do that anymore,
except for the 5G craziness,
because we live in an age of science
and hopefully we've moved past that.
So to me, once I left the
church and, really, religion,
I was still interested in
answering the big questions,
like, well, then where
did the universe came from
if there's no God?
What's the origins of morality?
What about consciousness?
Why is the universe tuned the way it is?
Where did all this
diversity of life come from?
All the great questions
from a secular perspective.
So in trying to answer
it myself, I thought,
well, I wanna write, so this
is what I'm gonna write about
from a skeptical perspective.
So my little niche, my lane as they say,
is kind of on the margins
of science, pseudoscience,
and the paranormal, the supernatural,
the controversial stuff that
most mainstream scientists
don't deal with.
That's my lane, and
from there I can tackle
the great questions, just from
my particular perspective.
So like I have a chapter in the book,
"Mr. Hume, Tear Down this Wall,"
and the one before it
defending scientific humanism.
The point of that is
I'm trying to get away
from this kind of NOMA,
as Steve Gould called it,
non-overlapping magisteria,
where Gould argued,
Most scientists tend to go this way,
that science and religion
are two different things,
and that you scientists
get the empirical world
and the religious people,
they get the world
of morality and meaning and purpose.
And I'm like, wait a minute.
Why can't we say something about that?
I mean, I don't believe in God,
but I still believe that there
are objective moral values.
How can that be, 'cause
there's no outside source?
Well, here's how it could be.
So I try to defend that.
Now, there is a technical problem
called the naturalistic fallacy
that my philosopher friends
tell me you can't debunk it.
So I tried to debunk it, they tell me,
"Well, you didn't quite do it."
But I'm not a philosopher,
I'm not trying to pretend to be one,
I'm just saying it's not a choice
between you either believe in God
and you go for the religious morality
or you're a relativist and anything goes,
you can never say something is wrong.
I don't like slavery, but
I can't say it's wrong.
I don't think the Jews
should have been exterminated
in the Holocaust, but I
can't say it's really wrong
to exterminate Jews.
Are you kidding me?
Yes, of course, we can say it's wrong.
Anyway, so that's kinda
where I'm coming from.
- Okay, man, you have teed me
up with so much stuff there,
and much of what you just
described is in the book,
and I really do wanna spend some time
focusing on this sort of mystical truth,
as you describe through
the Jordan Peterson lens
and the empirical truth
and the rest of it.
And we talked about this.
I just did your podcast,
and we've come to slightly
different conclusions on it,
and yet we're here and we're
still not killing each other.
So what I wanna start with first though
is just the title, actually, of the book,
because that really struck me,
"Giving the Devil His Due."
It seems actually quite reverse of the way
that most of us behave these days.
Perhaps not the two of us
right this very moment,
but so much of society seems to be based
on not giving the devil
his due, just finding,
oh, someone thinks something
differently than me,
that must mean that everything they think
and the summation of who they
are is somehow evil and wrong.
So when you came up with the title,
did that have a lot to do
with just how we seem to behave right now?
- Yes, yeah, I mean, absolutely.
I'm just finding the page
where I wanna start on this,
how this problem started,
because free speech
and free thought, that
used to be a liberal cause.
That was free speech, UC Berkeley, 1960s,
we're gonna stand up and think
and say whatever we want.
The comedians of the '50s
and '60s are pushing back
against the man, the power authority,
which was mostly the right
and the Christian right and Republicans.
It was, remember at the time,
Republicans mostly
wanting to censor things,
like burning the flag or
Madonna's videos or whatever,
because their argument was,
well, this could harm society.
People expressing
themselves in a certain way
can bring down the moral values
of our great God-given, whatever, country,
and therefore we have to combat that.
In a way, the left is now doing that,
saying, well, certain speech is harmful,
and harmfulness is a form of violence,
and we have to prevent violence,
and therefore censoring speech is okay.
That's kinda the thread,
and it really goes back,
I identify on the first page of the book,
this goes back to 1919
in the case of Schenck
versus the United States.
So this is the famous decision
by the Supreme Court Justice
Oliver Wendell Holmes
where shouting fire in a theater
and clear and present
danger phrases come from.
So here is his decision.
The most stringent
protection of free speech
would not protect a man
in falsely shouting fire
in a theater and causing a panic.
The question in every case
is whether the words used
are used in such circumstances
and are of such a nature
as to create a clear and present danger
that they will bring
about substantive evils
that Congress has a right to prevent.
Okay, what was this
clear and present danger?
This guy Schenck was the
head of the Socialist Party
in Philadelphia, and he was
printing and handing out flyers
to draft-age young men
who were being drafted.
Conscription was legal and
they were being drafted
and sent to Europe to die for our country.
And Schenck said, "Wait a minute,
"that's a violation of the 14th Amendment
"which protects your
bodily autonomy and right,
"and no one can take away your life."
But in a way, conscription in the draft,
that's a way of the government saying,
"We're taking over your life for a while,
"and you may die if we
order you to go do that."
Whoa, okay, now we can debate
that, that's a separate issue.
The thing is, how can that be
a clear and present danger?
That's the equivalent of shouting
fire in a crowded theater.
Well, now, by the 1960s, of course,
everybody's protesting the draft
and burning their draft cards
and running up to Canada or whatever,
and that was a liberal cause to say,
"You know what, that's going too far."
It has to be okay to have
those kinds of debates
and discussions and protests.
That's all protected by the Constitution,
and here is the U.S. Supreme Court saying,
"No, no, we can step in and..."
Okay, so fast forward to say
the civil rights movement
and the push in the '70s and '80s
to improve our speech, right?
So don't use the N word,
that's really harmful.
Okay, pretty much everybody will go,
"Yeah, yeah, that's right."
And by the way, the C word for women
and calling Jews kikes
and Vietnamese gooks,
and the bin starts
getting bigger and bigger,
like, yeah, that's hateful, it's harmful,
and therefore, it should be censored.
So it starts off with good intentions
on the part of the left,
like yeah, yeah.
- Of course, of course.
- And this moral progress starts.
But then by the '90s, the
bin is getting larger,
and then by a couple of years ago,
I reprinted in there the UC system's list
of microaggressions that are
harmful, hateful things to say,
things like, "Where are you from,"
or "Wow, you speak English so well."
(chuckles)
Or, "Why aren't you good at math?"
Or, "You are good at math."
- Right, you have a whole
chart laying this out, yeah.
- So you get mission creep.
- You have a whole chart
laying these things out, but, yeah.
So are you surprised though the way
the mission creep has
affected institutions
that were supposed to defend
these liberal principles?
The easiest one I can give
you is Nadine Strossen,
who you have the blurb
on the back of the book,
she was the head of the ACLU,
she is a free-speech absolutist.
She no longer is the head
now, she's since retired,
but she laid out in this very
room the very strong case
for why the Nazis should
have been allowed to march
in Skokie, Illinois.
It was a place where there
was a tremendous amount
of Holocaust survivors, but
the ACLU defended the freedom
of speech of a group of odious people
because that's what we're
supposed to do in this country,
where now even the ACLU is often suddenly
seemingly on the wrong
side of these things.
Are you surprised that
it's not just affected
individual people, but the
way that the mission creep
has affected the institutions
that were supposed to
stand up for this stuff?
- It has and I'm worried about that.
I don't know if they actually believe it
or if they're just scared
that they're gonna be canceled
and censored themselves or whatever.
I'm somewhat sympathetic
to some university administrators say
who kinda go along with it,
'cause they're scared of losing their jobs
or professors are afraid to say something.
But this is the problem,
this is the whole reason
for tenure in the first place,
was to protect liberal professors
from these right-wing kooks
who wanted to shut them down.
Now it's kinda reversed, and
so maybe we do need tenure
to protect these liberal professors
from their fellow leftists
or fellow liberals
who wanna cancel them, shut
them down, get them fired.
This is a perverse reversal of things
that has just gone haywire.
So, the devil in the title
is whoever you disagree with
and whoever disagrees
with you or you don't like
or you don't like what they say.
It's easy to grant free speech
to people you agree with,
that's not who it's for.
It's for the people that
don't agree with you.
Those are the voices we have to hear.
Okay, so to articulate
the reason is simply
one person's hate speech is
another person's free speech.
I got this from Nadine Strossen's book
that in 1850s, Southern politicians argued
that abolitionists from the
North coming into the South
to give sermons and speeches
and distribute pamphlets
about the evils of slavery,
that's a form of hate speech.
Now, they didn't use
that word, hate speech,
but they basically made the argument
that Justice Holmes made,
was that this could lead to
slave riots and insurrections,
and that could lead to
the murder of slave owners
and the disruption of our
peaceful plantation life
here in the South, and therefore
we have to censor that.
It's like, wow, if they
hadn't had this opportunity
to champion the abolition of slavery,
would we ever have gotten there?
And then in the 1960s, there
were arguments in the South,
again, made against
Malcolm X in particular
and Martin Luther King slightly less
that what they were saying was,
they, again, didn't use
the word hate speech,
but that this is potentially dangerous
to have them coming down
here to give these sermons
and speeches that rile people up
and they go out in the streets to protest,
wow, we can't have that.
(chuckles) Wait a minute, that's
how social change happens.
That's protected in the Constitution.
And again, these are liberal causes
that by now it's kind of flipped.
So we have to remind ourselves,
I'm trying to do it in this book,
is that, no, no, here
are the reasons, okay?
So I articulate them, like
Nadine did on your show.
It's like even if you're completely right,
you can learn something from
somebody else's arguments
to improve your own arguments.
As John Stewart Mill said,
he who knows his own side,
only his own side of the
case, doesn't even know that.
So like I have my students
watch Ben Shapiro's videos
arguing pro-life, 'cause most of them,
they don't know what the
pro-life arguments are.
So even if you end up being
pro-choice at the end,
you're better off now.
But maybe Ben's right about some points
or whatever the other side is.
Maybe you're completely wrong
and you can learn something new.
But mostly the devil part here
is for my safety's sake also,
that once I set up the
norms or laws or customs
or whatever to silence you,
well, what happens if I'm
now in the minority position
or I have the voice that
goes against the grain,
then I've already endorsed
the apparatus to shut me down.
So that's the best argument,
if you wanna take it from
kind of a selfish perspective,
to give the devil his due
for your own safety's sake.
- Yeah, and we see a
lotta that these days,
which is the people who are
running around screaming
that Trump is Hitler are the
ones that are also saying
that the federal government
isn't doing enough.
It's the same sort of idea.
- That's good.
- Like, oh, well, then maybe
we should be scaling back
if you were right in the first place.
But putting that aside for a second,
so I think this will
lead us to what I think
is really the most interesting stuff here.
As you talk about the way liberals
have sort of maybe lost
the plot along the way,
do you think that there is
a weakness in liberalism?
And I think this will sort of get us also
to the Jordan mystical verse
imperial truth part of this.
Do you think that there is a weakness
in the ideology of liberalism,
of the openness of liberalism,
that allows for all of
the bad ideas to come in
which sort of leads us
to a place right now
where liberals often don't
know what they believe,
while conservatives at the moment
seem to have a better ability
to fight off the social justice stuff,
the intersectionality
stuff, the progressive rot
that we see across society right now?
Is there something that is actually weak
in the very system of ideas
that I know you and I mostly subscribe to?
- Yeah, I want liberals
to own the First Amendment
like conservatives own the
Second Amendment, right?
I mean, it's just sacrosanct.
We are never giving this up.
We're drawing a line in
the sand, this is it.
But they've abandoned that in a way.
I think an explanation might
come from Karl Popper's,
the great philosopher of science,
Karl Popper's book, "The Open Society."
And so he made the argument
that there's something of a paradox
of being tolerant of intolerance,
and then therefore the intolerant
people can rise to power
because you've tolerated them,
and then they shut the whole system down.
This is kinda the argument in simplicity.
It's an issue that we should deal with,
but I'm not particularly
worried about that.
I think that's taking the
precautionary principle
like just in case the
intolerant people come to power,
we can't have that, so we should
start shutting people down.
Well, who do you shut down?
You know, the ones that
we think are intolerant.
Who, you?
That you think?
What, are we gonna have a committee set up
that decides this?
Again, pretty soon you're
shutting down this person
and that person, and half
the country is shut down,
and this is no good, right?
I think it's a bit of a--
- But is there something then
that liberalism can do?
Is there something that liberalism can do
to defend itself from that
because of that paradox?
I'll grant you that,
liberals are more open,
that's the idea of liberalism
that comes with a lotta good stuff,
like individual rights and
freedom, but then that openness,
and this is exactly what
Popper was talking about,
allows these guys to come in,
and then liberals seem to
scatter when the going gets rough
because they don't wanna be called bigots
and Nazis and the rest of it.
- Well, of course, no one
wants to be called that,
but the problem is, is that
you have to allow people
to say things like that, again,
for your own safety's sake.
It's a foundational principle
of all the other rights.
It stands below them.
It's the foundational rock,
say the pyramid platform,
upon which all the other stones are built,
those being the other rights.
If you don't have the freedom
to think and say what you want,
then all the other rights
that come from protesting,
from writing, speaking,
better ideas to replace the bad ideas,
which is pretty much the
history of civilization,
is just the improvement
of our understanding
of the cause of things in the world,
that's the only way to do it.
So to me the liberals have
to just remind themselves
of that foundation principal,
but also just sort of own that,
as like this is where we
draw the line in the sand.
This idea of diversity, so
it's a small step to say
you're in favor of
diversity, oh, yeah, totally.
How 'bout diversity of viewpoints?
It's called viewpoint diversity.
You have to put that in the same bin,
and that's where, of course, as you know,
they get a little crazy about that.
- So this is a good segue for us,
because what I'm finding right now
is that line in the sand
that we both want drawn,
it seems impossible for liberals
to do at a systemic level,
meaning the individuals, we've
talked about this many times,
that I believe individuals can do it,
but it seems like systems based on that
seem unable to stand up to it.
So I thought this would be a great segue
to talk about the differences
that you have with Jordan Peterson,
and I thought I have to
read actually the blurb
that Jordan wrote on the back of the book,
because I've literally never
seen a statement like this
written on the back of
someone's book before,
and that'll be a good launch point for us.
So Jordan wrote, this is
a rather difficult book
for me to blurb given
that an entire chapter
is devoted to criticizing my claims
about pragmatic truth
vis-a-vis scientific truth.
However, Dr. Michael Shermer
is a very clear thinker,
and the kind of skeptic
that is always necessary
to ensure that public thought,
scientific and otherwise,
maintains a certain clarity.
He's a passionate advocate of free speech,
for this and many other reasons,
to the point of entitling his new book,
"Giving the Devil His Due,"
which is devoted to
many worthwhile topics,
but to free speech above all.
Despite our disagreements,
this is a necessary book for our times.
Read it, and thank God
and the powers that be
that you have the right to do so.
So I think it's perfect
because it's a summation
of what we all know about Jordan,
but the fact that you asked him to do it,
despite having a chapter in here
which grapples with all of his ideas,
and I do think this is sort of linked
to the question that I'm
asking you about liberalism.
So can you can unpack
what your similarities
and differences are with Jordan?
- Yeah, I think when I first
saw Jordan on your show
and Joe's show, and
said, "Who is this guy?"
Like everybody else, "Who is this guy?"
(chuckles)
To me, I was dying to know
what it is he thought about things,
although at the same time I could see
mostly liberals again
trying to shut him down
or call him Hitler or whatever,
a bigot and a misogynist and whatnot,
and then when I met him, I thought,
"This guy is a super good guy."
I could see why I don't agree
with him on this and that,
but he's the kind of
person we should listen to.
There's a reason he
rose in such popularity,
because people are
resonating with his ideas.
Now, even if I don't, I
can at least recognize,
well, here's a voice maybe
I should pay attention to.
I might learn something from him.
So the two chapters at
the end of the book,
the chapter on Jordan and the
chapter on Graham Hancock,
who I was on Joe Rogan's podcast with
and then I got to know,
and it's like, okay,
this guy's an alternative archeologist,
he has some ideas that most
archeologists think are crazy
or way out there or not substantiated,
and yet he makes some
pretty good arguments,
he's a great writer,
and from there I think
this is the kind of people
we gotta give a voice to
and acknowledge that
maybe we don't have time
to listen to every
single person out there,
but pick and choose the
ones that are very popular,
because they must be saying something
that resonates with people.
Now, Jordan's theory of truth,
it's sort of a blend of Charles
Darwin and William James,
sort of an evolutionary pragmatism.
I don't wanna misquote his theory.
You can listen to four hours of him
and say I'm kinda hashing this out,
it goes on for that long,
and his books kinda deconstruct all that.
But near as I could tell,
it would be something like,
if you believe it's true and it works,
pragmatically speaking,
then you can use the word truth to it.
And I think it comes down
to, what do you mean by that?
Was Jesus resurrected from the dead?
Now, most Christians
today say yes, absolutely.
Someone named Jesus
existed, he was crucified
and he rose from the dead,
and 100 billion people have lived and died
before this 7 1/2
billion people alive now.
Not one of them has
come back from the dead,
except this one maybe.
So that's the argument.
Now from a skeptic's perspective,
I would say, well, that
is an extraordinary claim.
How extraordinary?
100 billion to one extraordinary, right?
Is the evidence for it, corresponding,
or in proportion to that
100 billion to one odds?
And the answer is no,
so I write about that.
But to Jordan, I think he would say
whether it happened or not is irrelevant.
It's mythically true or
psychologically true.
That is, you have a cross
to bear, you might say,
a burden to carry of the
suffering of yourself
and your family and friends
or humanity or whatever,
forgiveness, starting over,
this kind of resurrection
of your own life to rebuild.
It's like the Noachian flood story.
It's a story of
destruction and redemption.
It's a kind of a born-again story.
So I think what Jordan is arguing
is that has mythic power
that is a kinda truth
about the reality--
- That's like an eternal truth
underneath the empirical truth,
something like that, right?
- Right, that's right.
So it could be that
people like me and Jordan,
or maybe someone like
Richard Dawkins and Jordan,
or whoever that's kind of an empiricist,
they're just talking at two
different levels, I think.
(chuckles)
Jordan's not always
super clear about this,
so you have to kind of read what he said
here or other or whatever,
but I think that's what's going on.
And so to the extent that he
likes to quote Jung and Freud
and Nietzsche and Tolstoy and so on,
and Shakespeare, Jane Austen,
the reason this is great literature
is because it's tapping something
about the reality of human nature,
human relationships, human societies,
conflict, power struggles, sex,
and gossip, and conflict,
and violence, war.
Those are all realities
that everybody knows,
and these great novelists
can tap into that.
There's a whole study now
of evolutionary psychology of literature,
where they do a content
analysis of great works
to see which themes come
up over and over and over,
and the deepest themes
that we call care about,
again the sort of hierarchy,
social status, power,
deception, honesty, love, sex, all that.
And so there I think
what Jordan is arguing
that I would agree with,
that there are truths there,
but that's different
than an empirical truth.
So the analogy I make is like
people will often send me,
as the editor of "Skeptic" magazine,
articles explaining what
really happened with the flood,
a meteor strike or it
was a volcano eruption,
not the flood, but the
parting of the Red Sea say,
but the flood also, or
Jesus was on the cross,
and then somebody gave him
this chemical through the rag
and that put him into a coma,
and then they put him in the
tomb, and then he woke up.
- Many versions of this.
- And then his disciples
whisked him off to France.
Yeah, and he married Mary
Magdalene and they had kids,
and the bloodline is still around.
This was of course Dan Brown's novel.
That was a real book, actually.
Before Dan Brown, there was a book
called "Holy Blood, Holy Grail."
Actually, those guys sued Dan
Brown for stealing their idea.
He's like, "It's a novel, dude."
(laughing)
- Huh, is that right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He sold so many books.
Man, if you don't sell any books,
no one's gonna sue you
'cause there's no money.
So it was kinda funny.
But there you saw the difference.
Dan Brown's novel resonated
'cause it's just a story.
He's not claiming its empirically true,
but these guys, "The Holy
Blood, Holy Grail" authors,
they were saying, "No,
no, this really happened."
Okay, so those are two different ways
of saying really happened or truth.
- So do you think it's possible
that we need both of those?
I think maybe that's the position
that I've come around to,
that we need empirical truths,
we need scientific truths absolutely,
but when you talk about that other layer
that Jordan's talking about,
the time-tested things
about purpose and
happiness and individualism
and the drive to accomplish what humans
are sort of here to do,
that for me I've come to,
and this is one of the spots
when I was just on your show
you were asking about, 'cause
I write about this in my book,
I've come to the place where for society
to organize itself properly,
it does need some other ethos beneath it.
And what I think is something
like when you talk about Shakespeare
and all the authors that
write about these themes too,
that in and of themselves,
those stories aren't enough
to organize a society around.
Not that again that
individuals can't do it,
but for actually for a
society to function properly.
Do you think there's some truth to that?
- Yeah, I do, for sure.
There's a reason why drama
films and television sells
or has much bigger viewerships
than documentary films.
It's very rare any documentary
film gets millions of views.
There's a few, but not many.
And the reason is because
we're storytelling animals
and we're moved emotionally,
deeply psychologically moved
by a story about some person.
Like when Spielberg
made "Schindler's List,"
it's not the story of the Holocaust
because that's too big a subject.
You could have like a
Ken Burn's 13-part series
on the Holocaust, people have done this,
'cause there's so many stories to tell.
Instead, he just took one little story.
This guy, Oskar Schindler,
who was this guy?
Keneally wrote that novel about him,
sort of a semi-true novel.
If you really look at it,
it's not that interesting,
the story, but when you
bring it on the big screen
and then you build in the
Holocaust around that story,
but it's the narrative
thread that goes throughout.
So all filmmakers know this.
Most of us nonfiction writers,
we don't understand you
gotta have a narrative story,
you gotta have an arc to it
that pulls readers along.
Good writers do that and
good filmmakers do this.
So there is something in the human mind
about grasping ideas and
holding them in a way,
yammering away at a
blackboard giving a lecture,
which I do for a living,
that's not nearly as powerful
as somebody who could tell just one story
about this one person who
had this happen to him,
and then you embed in there
some ethical principle
or some conflict.
Essentially, you could tell the story
of the trolley problem in some drama
and that would be far more effective
than me giving an explanation
with a PowerPoint slide
showing the guy on the track
and the five workers and the one worker,
(laughing)
or yammering on about Kant categorically.
- So basically, if you
could spend five years
studying at Cambridge with the greatest
biblical scholars of all time,
and you could get them to sort of...
If you could find a
scholar who would basically
remove all of the stuff that
can't be empirically true,
empirically proved, sorry, but
that the lessons were lessons
that you believed to be mystically true,
you could come around to
those stories, basically.
You don't think those things
are mutually exclusive.
That's I think really
what I'm trying to get.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I just had Bart Ehrman on my podcast
and asked him this very thing,
'cause he was a Christian for a long time,
and now he's an atheist.
But I said, "Could you be a Christian
"and not believe in the
literal resurrection of Jesus?
"I think it's mythically true,
"psychologically true, whatever,"
and he goes, "Yeah, lots of Christians
"used to believe that."
That was the main thing until really
just the last century and a half or so
with the rise of science
and the power of science.
Believers feel like,
"Well, I can't just say
"it's true for me or
it's my faith tradition
"and I can't prove it."
There's a sense that now
you actually have to make an argument,
like this is why it's really true,
not just psychologically
true and true for me,
my faith tradition.
So creationists went down this road
in the early 20th century.
We have to argue that the
flood really happened.
Okay, that means we gotta study geology,
we gotta figure out how
floods do this to that
and rocks and blah, and
they're still doing that
to a certain extent, and
it never gets them anywhere
because, A, they don't
have very good arguments,
B, science has better arguments
for the flood or whatever,
and in any case, once
you go down that road
and you go, well, what happens
if science fills that gap,
are you gonna abandon
your Christian faith?
Well, no, because that's
not why I believe.
Right.
(chuckling)
- Have you found some
people like that though,
that they get to that place
and science fills the hole,
and then they suddenly walk?
Or do you find that more
people walk from religion
because of some other inconsistency
or some other personal ax to
grind or something like that?
- For personal reasons is
the main reason people leave.
There's this meme saying you can't reason
somebody out of something
they didn't reason
their way into in the first place.
That's not true.
We do this all the time,
skeptics and scientists or whatever,
and the research from Hugo Mercier
and other cognitive
psychologists that study this
show that you can talk
people out of beliefs,
you can reason them out.
But just collectively on average,
I think most people come to religion
or they leave religion
for personal reasons.
They come there, they
were raised that way,
or their spouse is that way,
or their peer group in
high school, like my case,
and they leave for other personal reasons.
Like after the Holocaust, a
lotta Jews became atheists,
like where was God, the
problem of theodicy again.
And in my case, when I finally gave it up
after seven years at the
end of graduate school,
I didn't tell anybody, I
just quit talking about it.
And I think my family was kinda relieved,
because I was always
yammering away about Jesus.
Witnessing is what it's
called, witnessing.
And I think they were sick
of it, so they were like,
"Thank God, Michael stopped
talking about that."
(laughing)
And I think that's usually what happens.
- So as a guy that now talks
about some other stuff,
the subtitle of the book
is "Reflections of a Scientific Humanist,"
and you mentioned that phrase earlier.
Can you explain exactly what that is?
- Yeah, so humanism has been
around really for a long time.
Secular humanism is a movement,
it kinda rose in the '30s and '40s,
very left-wing liberal, again,
free speech, free thought,
women's rights, civil rights,
African American rights,
and on and on, and so that was great.
But then by the '90s and early 2000s,
it shifted not just further to the left,
but also this kinda tribal
ticking of the boxes,
like here are the 12 things
secular humanists believe.
Well, I can tick like
eight of the 12 boxes.
Can I still be a humanist?
And it became, no, you're out.
If you don't tick all
12 boxes, you're out!
(laughing)
I forget what you called
it, but it was the narcism
of small differences?
- Well, it's the narcism
of small differences, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, I love that phrase.
- The narcism of small differences.
It's a great phrase.
- That's not mine originally.
I don't know who came up with it.
- Oh, okay, all right.
And then Pinker started calling
it enlightenment humanism.
I like that, sometimes I use that phrase,
but really in those chapters,
I'm arguing that science
has something to say
about human values and morals
and ethical theories and so on,
even if you can't perfectly
debunk the naturalistic fallacy
and go from is to ought,
the way things are to the
way things they ought to be.
Maybe technically that's not possible,
but again, I don't care about that.
I'm just saying this binary choice
between divine command theory,
that is God said it and that
makes it right or wrong,
versus relativism, anything goes,
there are no real moral values,
I just don't believe that.
I quote Abraham Lincoln,
if slavery is not wrong,
nothing is wrong.
And I can say if the
Holocaust is not wrong,
nothing is wrong.
Show me a society where people say,
"I really wanna be enslaved,"
or most people in a group say,
"Yeah, I really think we
should be exterminated."
This is insane, nobody thinks that.
We all know why that's wrong.
We're born knowing that that's wrong.
Now, set aside crazy psychopaths
that just like murdering people,
most of us have a sense
of right and wrong.
That comes from our nature.
So I have long arguments
about the evolutionary
origins of morality and so forth,
but the idea again is just to
counter this binary choice.
There's more of that.
So I call it scientific humanism
or call it enlightenment humanism.
But let's not make the tent so small
that only a few people
can tick all 12 boxes.
That's a bad road to go
down, and for some reason,
a lotta social movements do that.
I remember when
objectivism was on the rise
when I was at Pepperdine.
I mentioned everybody
read "Atlas Shrugged,"
right?
- Yeah.
- And then she died in '82, so
there was this big movement,
but then the biographies
about her came out
that showed the movement was shrinking
as they were kicking people out.
You watch the wrong films,
you listen to the wrong music.
That's not objectivist music.
(laughing) What?
Even smoking the wrong brand of cigarettes
became the non-objectivist
form of cigarette smoking.
Pretty soon, there's like
six people at her funeral.
There's nobody left.
- You know, it's so
interesting, 'cause as you know,
I do some speaking events
with the Ayn Rand Institute.
I think we've done at least
one together, didn't we?
I think we did something
with Ayn Rand together,
maybe at USC or something,
and I think actually the top brass there,
I don't wanna speak for them,
but I think they really do regret
some of exactly what you're talking about,
making it so hysterical in nature.
But you know when you
mentioned Ayn Rand before
and being at Pepperdine,
it is sort of interesting,
because you have all these people
that come from a religious
background reading a book
about really from the ultimate
individualist capitalist
who truly was a secularist too,
because she did a mass
dissection of religion
and really was completely anti-religion,
yet somehow these people were
able to read these things,
and I guess it didn't work
out that well in the end,
but they were trying to
put these pieces together,
which is kinda interesting.
- Yeah, for sure, the new
generation of Ayn Rand supporters
are much more ecumenical about that.
I think in the earlier
generation when Rand was alive,
I think they said Friedrich
Hayek and Ludwig von Mises
and Milton Friedman were
basically socialist.
It's like, what?
(laughing)
These guys are like hardcore libertarian.
They're not libertarian
enough, you're out!
(laughing)
- No, seriously.
- Although, according to...
Well, according to "The New York Times,"
Milton Friedman's leading
people to the alt-right,
didn't you know that?
I mean, that's how it works.
- That's right, that's right.
But again, I think all
social movements do that.
- We only have a little bit of time left,
I wanna move on to some of
the ways that you tackle
the issues of the day through this lens.
So let's talk about guns a little bit,
because basically you talk
about it's sorta just the lens
that liberals and conservatives are using
to look at the issue
that is sorta the problem
in the first place.
- Yeah, guns, I have a couple
of chapters in the book
on guns because I did these
debates with John Lott,
the author of that book,
"More Guns, Less Crime."
So he's pretty hardcore.
You see him a lot on TV
defending the Second Amendment and so on.
Okay, fine, I'm not a critic
of the Second Amendment.
I'm concerned about the
levels of gun violence.
It's 35 to 40,000 a year die of guns.
Shouldn't we do something about this?
The automobile industry did this.
Let's put seatbelts in
and airbags and so on.
And why doesn't the gun
manufacturers do this?
The NRA used to do that.
The NRA was a gun safety club
that insisted on training
people on the use of guns.
Okay, I'm fine with guns as
long as you have training
and you keep it in a locked box and so on.
But the problem is, is
that I think the right now
has fetishized the Second Amendment
such that guns are a
proxy for something else.
It's not the guns they're defending.
It's that guns represent
freedom, autonomy, liberty,
the right for me to protect myself
and my family and my home.
Well, isn't that what
law enforcement is for?
Yeah, but they can't be there on time,
and they're not always reliable.
Therefore, it's up to me.
That's a very American way
of thinking about this issue.
And so I look at some of
those issues in the book, too.
It's a hard one, I know,
because I have no solution to this, Dave.
There's 350 million guns in America.
We're not gonna confiscate them all.
The Second Amendment's
not gonna be tossed out.
It's never gonna happen.
But the idea, like shouldn't
we just have background checks
and close the gun show loophole,
and just little things?
But the moment you go down that path,
the people on far end of that spectrum,
they go, "Oh, no, that's a slippery slope
"and pretty soon it's Hitlers
marching in the streets
"taking away everybody's guns."
Come on, we should at least
be able to talk about it.
- Yeah, there's so much there.
I mean, 350 million guns as you say,
that's more than people
in the United States,
that's one thing,
but do you think in a time
like we're in right now,
where the reason we're
not doing this in studio
is obviously because of coronavirus,
and it's pretty miraculous
we've talked for 50 minutes
and not even mentioned it, which is nice,
but that in a time like right
now where we sees stories
where New York City's letting out
a certain amount of prisoners,
and we're closing gun shops in LA,
and the government seems
to be taking these,
what I would say are strange,
somewhat radical measures,
that it actually feeds
that very American idea,
even if you're not
thrilled with that idea,
that you could see why someone
would think the way they think?
- Yeah, yeah, for sure.
A couple of gun rights groups sued Newsom
and the state of California,
insisting that gun shops
are a essential commodity,
like pharmacies and
supermarkets should stay open,
so should gun shops.
Wow, okay, really? (chuckles)
Do you really believe,
even if the great America
is on the precipice of
collapsing at any moment,
the currency's gonna be useless
and within a matter of weeks,
there'll be mobs in the street?
I better packing heat and have my home
fully loaded up and ready to shoot people.
Come on, don't you have more confidence
in the American system of law and order
and civil society than that?
And apparently, some people don't.
- I think it's shaking, I really do.
Listen, I wish we could go longer,
but we're crunched over here.
But we will do this in
person the second we can,
and we'll pick it up, 'cause
there's so much more in here.
It's a dense, thoughtful
book, and I really enjoyed it.
This is now at least
your seventh appearance
on "The Rubin Report,"
so I suspect it will continue.
- Well, thanks, Dave.
No, you're one of the people I think of
with "Giving the Devil."
You do give the Devil their due
and you get hammered for it.
But you gotta absorb it,
because that's the only way.
I listen to your show all the time.
There's people I never even heard of.
It's like, wow, that's an
incredibly interesting idea.
That's the only way we can
learn and make progress.
- Indeed, my friend.
Well, I look forward to
seeing you in person,
and it'll be better done
than through these pipes
that Al Gore developed.
So, good seeing you,
Michael, thanks so much.
And we'll link to the book
right down below.
- Okay, bye-bye.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about academia
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our academia playlist,
and if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.